just watched the president there and he
says he's starting to feel good but
there have of course been these
conflicting reports about the
president's Health what's the UK
government been told about the condition
of the president well I think we've all
just seen I mean for somebody who's uh
been suffering with uh coid over the
last few days and obviously has been in
hospital I have to say looks in pretty
good uh strength there to me as I saw
the the interview earli on with Naj far
I think the point he was making was a
fair point he looks in pretty good
health um obviously it's it's a matter
for him and his uh Medical team but uh
but that's that that looked like
somebody who's uh pretty straightforward
and able to explain where they are and
what they're doing and and their hopes
for the future of their country I guess
some of the skepticism felt by some of
the UK may come from what happened with
Boris Johnson and there are these kind
of Echoes of what happened with the
Prime Minister here you know we were
told at the time that he was in good
spirits that moving to hospital was just
precautionary and of course he ended up
in intensive care it felt like number 10
weren't upfront with us about the prime
minister's health health do you think
there is a risk the same thing is
happening in the White House well a
couple of things I'd say is first of all
with the Prime Minister here just a
couple of days before he was in hospital
I was on a conference call with him and
he was speaking fine and and seem to be
doing very very well and I think it's a
reminder actually what we saw with the
prime minister of two things first of
all we're a few months on from that and
this is still a new virus I mean this
virus has been with us for under about a
year now uh we're still learning things
as we go forward and I think that the
learning over the last few months would
have made a difference in terms of how
people are being treated and how car's
being taken forward but I think again
it's also a reminder the second point I
would make is um how quickly this can
move and the impact this can have and as
was said I think on your show earlier I
mean that clip there the prime the
president looks in a relatively good
State bearing in mind what he's been
going through over the last few days but
it's over the next five to seven days
that you get that point at the seven to
day 7 to 10 day period where you really
know if that virus is going to bite in a
particular way or not so I think it's
one of those points we have to remember
this virus can hit very quickly it
affects different people in different
ways but we are learning new things
about it as we go forward and the the
scientists and the experts are shown
that with the progress they're making on
the vaccines and things like that and
actually as even the President says the
next few days will be the real test he
says of of his recovery and the
treatment for uh coid the other thing I
wanted to ask about is do you think
there's a risk of a bit of a macho
culture here you know you've got the
president and Boris Johnson doing these
video messages showing that they're
still working through coid they're in
their suits and actually would it not be
a better example example to say look we
need to rest this is a serious virus we
need to take it seriously well I think
to be fair I think we have been saying
to people you've got to take the virus
seriously I don't d by Leading by by
example it does feel this what Nigel FR
described as like an alpha male sort of
culture well I think there is always an
element of anybody who's involved in
public life who's leading a team of
people wants to show that they are still
able to to lead and we have to give
their team confidence about what they're
doing I think to be fair the Prime
Minister if you remember when he was fit
and able to was putting messages out
both from hospitle and then quickly
video messages outlining how Illy he'd
been outlining how not just thanking
people but thanking the NHS for the
amazing work they've been doing for him
and for others and I think that
highlighted an understanding of just how
this through it as well though wasn't he
yeah I think we've got a we've got a
prime minister who's absolutely
passionate and focused on delivering for
people across the country and wants to
make sure that we are continuing to do
that and we do everything he can at
every point to deliver on that for the
benefit of people across the UK okay uh
now I'm Keen to pick up on the film that
we showed a few moments ago about local
lockdowns these posto lockdowns if you
like uh which seem a really key part of
the government strategy they're not
working are they well I think they are
actually I would I would I would
disagree with you on that Sophia I think
first of all that the World Health
Organization said the approach we're
taking is strong it's decisive they've
they've been complimentary about that
we've seen areas like L and leester who
have gone into lockdown we've seen the
benefits of that their numbers have
eased again we've been a to change the
situation in those places I accept there
are some parts of the country I think
you just had greater main strong where
numbers are continuing to rise and we've
got to keep an eye on that it's why it's
so important that we all follow these
guidelines and actually use the the very
simple things about washing our hands
keeping our face covered and keeping
space but if you look at the data
Leicester is the only area of a local
lockdown that now has lower case numbers
Luton yes dropped after the restrictions
came in but numbers have gone back up
again everywhere else the case numbers
are higher now than when the restriction
started I think we can show you the data
from greater Manchester where we've been
focusing now they've been in lockdown
for 9ine weeks you can see the second
line there where the extra restrictions
began and cases have gone up fourfold in
that time what this doesn't look like a
strategy that's working to me well I
think I I would say it's quite a stark
reminder I think Luton is a good example
about how it's a reminder we mustn't
lose vigilance we all have our own self-
responsibility around making sure that
we are following the guidelines and
making sure that you know wherever we
live we keep an eye on the government
website which gives the details of where
you live in particular and if you're in
somewhere like greater Manchester um not
doing that social mixing as we're
advising people to do following the
guidelines because this virus does
spread when you're face Toof face with
people when you're in close contact with
people if you're not following the
guidelines the virence of this virus is
frightening and we've got to make sure
that we all take responsibility for
breaking that that curve so looking at
those increasing case numbers are people
in grapes Manchester not following the
guidelines well all the data research
doing is what the department of health
will continue to look at to assess
whether we've got the right restrictions
in place at the right time in the right
places following what's happening there
I did see Andy Burnham at the moment
just saying that his views that people
in gr mancher are the majority and
following the guidelines I think across
the country I have to say I think the
majority of people are following the
guid but can I just give you example of
this you can see sometimes how one
outbreak in one area can very quickly
move we've seen this even in Norfolk
where we had an issue with a particular
company that's in an isolated place of
course the people work there if you're
not careful when they go go home again
can very quickly spread this virus very
very easily so it's why it's so
important that we all keep that
vigilance you were saying about how the
Department of Health is monitoring how
people are following the rules what does
the data on compliance show well at the
moment as as Andy B just said I think we
think people are the majority of people
are flowing these rules everyone but we
well that's why we've made sure we're
being clear with people that the
enforcement is there we're putting
bigger penalties in place to remind
people actually hopefully to get people
to see how important this is and why it
matters and and let me just say so to
anybody watching this today everything
we do has an impact it has an impact not
just on our own health and if somebody
feels that they can Brave through this
and don't need to do something it's the
impact it has on their friends their
family and on the NHS and our ability to
manage and deal with this virus as
quickly as we can so you say that the
data shows that people the majority of
people are following the rules but what
is the actual compliance data can you
give it to us well I can't give you the
details of the compliance data now what
we're looking what we're looking
we are publishing as much data as we can
as often as we can and but on on testing
as well as you saw as you showed in your
clip just a little bit earlier on one of
the other issues of course in
understanding how many cases we've got
is we're doing so much more testing more
than pretty much anywhere else in Europe
one of the most comprehensive programs
of testing anywhere in the world and
that also obviously is allows us to
identify more and more cases which
allows us to understand where this virus
is spreading and how it's spreading on
the testing which has you say it's a
really important you know tool in our
kit for trying to keep on top of the
virus a technical issue meant that 12,
872 cases were added to the total
yesterday yeah when you yourself
acknowledge how important that is to
work out where the virus is where it's
spreading what went wrong well this is a
an issue between the 24th of September
and the 1st of October those numbers
have been put in as of yesterday which
is as you say it's had that impact on
the numbers I would say actually this is
a testimony to how focused Department of
Health Public Health England and test
and Trace and HS are around that we're
being that we're being transparent about
this we're publishing the figures as
daily as soon as their spotted has been
an issue they've dug into that they've
got to the bottom of those numbers
they've been transpo and publish the
correct numbers and of course the teams
will be looking through how that
happened to be sure it doesn't happen
again all the way through this we've
been looking at how we can share
information with the public as quickly
as we can as transparently as we can
because that's part of explaining to
people just how dangerous and how
quickly this virus is in the way that it
spreads okay we've been talking a lot
about compliance how important it is
that people follow the rules and you can
see why people might wonder why they
should follow the rules of other people
flout them we saw the case of Margaret
fer uh the MP who took that train from
London to glasgo knowing she had just
tested positive for Corona virus now the
S&P acted pretty swiftly they stripped
with the whip and this is what Nicholas
sturgeon had to say she said I've spoken
to Margaret fer and made clear my view
that she should step down as an MP her
actions were dangerous and indefensible
and I just want to compare that to what
Boris Johnson said this is what he said
about Margaret fer I think that's very
much a matter for the Scottish national
party and for Nicholas sturgeon what I
would say about the rules is certainly
that everyone should obey them I mean
that is a pretty wooly statement and I
just put it to you we all know the real
reason that Boris Johnson isn't going
out there and really criticizing
Margaret fer is because he doesn't want
to be accused of hypocrisy when Dominick
Cummings kept his job after breaking the
rules actually I think there's more than
that I don't think that's that's a fair
assessment at all I think they're very
different situations apart from you know
we I've commented before about the
situation with Dominic and the fact that
actually um within the guidelines I
don't it wasn't on the same scale at all
of what margar I'm not trying to compare
the scale I'm comparing the reaction
they're both breaking rules that
everyone else expected to well I'm not
sure that's entirely correct but
Margaret certainly has done and what she
has done by traveling on public
transport knowing she's got a positive
test is a whole different level it's
exactly what nobody should be doing I
think what the prime minister's um
statement is his belief that we all have
to follow self- respon take care and
responsibility for our own actions and
that's something Margaret should
certainly do I'm amazed she's still a
member of the SMP bnie Mar what Nicholas
sturgeon has done that would be the
right action to take Margaret needs to
do the right thing as well okay um can
you talk a bit about brexit how
optimistic are you that we're going to
get a trade deal well I'm always an
optimist I think it's I've always said I
think a trade deal is
interest of our partners in the EU as
much it's in our interest I think the
negotiations are moving forward in a Str
a very structured way I think we saw the
statement yesterday from um the Prime
Minister and Mr veline and around the
fact we're going to continue that work
to try and get through these last few
issues that hopefully mean we can get to
a full and proper Free Trade Agreement
now the EU said this week that it was
going to take legal action against the
UK uh for passing the legislation that
could override parts of the uh
withdrawal agreement now I just want to
play a quick video what you said about
the internal markets Bill last month
just have a little
lesson friend yes this does break inter
law in a very speciic a very specific
and limited way we are taking the power
to disapply the EU law concept of direct
effect required by article four in a
certain very tightly defined
circumstances now there's been an awful
lot said about that phrase you used
breaking international law in a limited
and specific way so I just want to know
what happened were you reading from a
script who who wrote it uh well I think
you can see that I'm very clearly
reading from a script I wanted to be
well because I wanted to be very clear
that I was given a very straight answer
to a very specific question what you
haven't played there is what Bob Neil um
asked he asked a very specific question
I'm a very firm believer if somebody
asks you a straight question you give
wherever you can as much of a straight
answer as you can within the best
knowledge that you have got well well
because with with the Urgent question
that we had it seemed to me obvious that
somebody was going to ask that very
specific question script well the script
was something that we put together at
the Northern Ireland office and it's
it's a direct answer to the question but
I would just say that number 10
involvement in it let me just say this
one of the things that's very clear and
this the point you made about the
European Union that they've issued about
800 letters of that type I think in the
last year alone to different on
different issues to different countries
our focus is on securing a Free Trade
Agreement in finishing the work of the
specialist joint committee which is
particularly focused on the Northern
Island protocol and these Clauses that
we're talking about are the Clauses that
mean we ensure that Northern Island
businesses have unfetter access to the
UK Market something we promis something
the protocol itself promises and
something EU says that it is supports us
and our drive to deliver the reason that
I kind of brought back to what you said
there about breaking the law in a
limited and specific way is because you
know after the outcry it felt like other
members of the cabinet distance them
themselves from what you said you know
your colleagues didn't exactly Row in
behind you well think you were thrown
onto the bus no not at all the the
Attorney General's legal position on
this also fully supported what I was
saying and the point we've made
consistently through this is we want to
secure all of the right deal through the
Free Trade Agreement through the
specialist joint committee we've always
said we want to give that certainty to
Northern iseland businesses that they'll
have what we promised in our Manifesto
as say in our Command paper which was
warmly and positively received including
by the EU actually and this is
delivering on that and it's a safety n
it's purely an insurance policy that
means we can deliver on that because if
we get to that point it's because
everything else is broken down because
the specialist joint committee which is
part of delivering the protocol hasn't
completed we are determined to ensure
that we protect the peace and prosperity
of Northern Ireland and that means
delivering on that promise of unfettered
access